CBS News has learned President Trump is
leaning towards D certifying the Iran
nuclear deal the president is looking to
force the issue by declaring Tehran out
of compliance with the landmark
agreement the 2015 deal froze Iran's
nuclear program in exchange for lifting
sanctions Secretary of State rec Tilson
discussed the agreement yesterday with
Iran's top diplomat Margaret Brennan is
at the United Nations four other
countries that signed the deal say they
want mr. Trump to stay in it Margaret
good morning good morning while
president Trump is now seeking to reopen
the Iranian nuclear deal rather than
scrap it all together and he's using
that threat of de certifying Iran's
compliance to try to force all parties
to renegotiate president Trump teased
reporters telling them he'd made up his
mind but offered no details Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson who met with Iran's
top diplomat said the president did not
inform him or anyone of his decision
Prime Minister may asked him if she if
he would share with her and he said no
UK prime minister Teresa may implores
mr. Trump not to decertify the landmark
agreement unraveling the deal could
trigger a diplomatic crisis with the
other five countries including China and
Russia who negotiated it that deal is an
embarrassment to the United States
Iran's president Hassan rouhani told
reporters Wednesday that the proposal to
renegotiate is fruitless the deal is
closed he said is there a diplomatic way
out rouhani replied that negotiations
with the US would be a waste of time and
that the Iranian people deserve an
apology after mr. Trump called their
government a murderous regime secretary
tiller sent on Wednesday night all of
this together looks like the atmosphere
diplomacy is getting worse how do you
respond to this there's a longtime
negotiator I learned to never say never
and second it always gets the darkest
before you might have a breakthrough now
behind the scenes French diplomats are
trying to
find a compromise Gayle today that other
nuclear threat North Korea takes center
stage as president Trump meets with the
leaders of Japan and South Korea all
right Thank You Margaret